اهلا بكم من رياض نواصل وتغطياتنا لنزاع
المسلح في السودان صراع الجنرلين مستمر
ولا افق واضحه لنهايته حتى له
[موسيقى]
ايام المعارك والمواجهات في السودان ايام
مليئه بالرصاص والضحايا من مدنيين
وعسكريين في احدث التطورات دعت قوات الدعم
السريع بقياده الى تمديد الهدنه الحاليه
لتشمل عيد الفطر في وقت تتجدد فيه عمليات
تبادل اطلاق النار بالقرب من شارع المطار
المؤدي الى القياده العامه بالخرطوم مكتب
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه اكد
للعربيه ان الموقف العملياتي مستقر حتى
الان مضيفا بان حده هجمات قوات الدعم
السريعه تراجعت على محيط القياده العامه
واضح الناطق باسم الجيشان القوات الجويه
وجاءت ضربات مركزه على ارتال عسكريه للدعم
السريع كانت في طريقها الى الخرطوم منظمه
الصحه العالميه كشفت عن مقتل 330 شخصا
واصابه ثلاثه الاف200 اخرين جراء
الاشتباكات في السودان وداعات الصحه
العالميه جميع الاطراف في السودان لهدنه
انسانيه للسماح للمواطنين بالحصول على
الرعايه الط
بعد 48 ساعه من سيطره الجيش السوداني على
مطار وقاعده مروي شماليه السودان اصطحب
زميل نزار بقداوي كاميرا العربيه في جوله
داخل المطار ورصادا الاضرار في المطار
وحيث تضرر برج المراقبه بشكل كبير جراء
الاشتباكاتي بين الجيش والدعم السريع
الجديد باننا الان داخل هذا المطار وداخل
القاعده العسكريه العملياتيه في مدينه
مروي هذا هو برج المراقبه الرئيس للقاعده
وللمطار هذا البرج الذي كنا يوم امس في
هذه النقطه وقد عكسنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق
به
هذه الاجهزه اكيزه التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادار محمد
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه من الان كان نتيجه
اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع ام تدمير
للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي كانت
موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار
لحق بالقاعده لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده
وهذا المطار الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات
في المنطقه الاقليميه لانه يطل على
الاتجاه الشمالي للسودان على حدود السودان
مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
معنا من الخرطوم وراس العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم ضعناه في اخر المستجدات في
العاصمه الخرطوم بخصوص المواجهات الان في
المناطق والمحاور التي تتركز فيها
المشاهدين
تزايدت وتيره الاشتباكات وكذلك الهجمات في
مناطق متفرقه وكان
كثير من هذه الاشتباكات معتمده على الجو
بشكل كبير الطيران الحربي كان محلقا في
شمال الخرطوم
هنا في مدينه بحري كانت التركيز على
الهجمات في منطقه المظلات بالقرب من كبري
شباك جسر شمات الرابط
وكذلك في منطقه كافوري كذلك في هذه
المناطق
هو في مسافه قريبه جدا وكان الاشتباك بصوت
عالي بحيث انه
المواطنين اذا كانوا لا يستطيعون الخروج
حاله من الزعر في هذه المناطق المحيطه او
القريبه من جسر شابات وكذلك المحيطه
والقريبه من منطقه كافوري مضادات الطائرات
كانت ايضا بصوت عالي جدا وفي مناطق كبيره
في حله حمد كذلك وفي جسر وفي كارفور كذلك
وايضا كانت هنالك اشتباكات في منطقه كوبر
هذا مجمل
مجمل الاشتباكات التي كانت في مدينه بحري
اين تتركز الاشتباكات الان
الان في هذه اللحظات هناك هدوء نسبي في
منطقه بحري قبل قليل كان صوت المدافع
بصوره واضحه في ذات المناطق ايضا هناك
اشتباكات اخرى في مدينه الخرطوم وكذلك في
ام درمان في ام درمان ايضا كان هناك طيران
الحربي مجموعه من الهجمات على المناطق
التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع
ما مدى حجم الدعم الذي يصل الى قوات الدعم
السريعه حاليا
نعم الدعم السريع تحدث تحدث الجيش
السوداني في بيانه انه كبده خسائر فادحه
وان هناك كان هناك امدادات في طريقها
للوصول لقوات الدعم السريع وان الجيش
السوداني قد دمر هذه الامدادات تماما قبل
وصولها الى الخرطوم هنا في هذه الاجواء
ايضا هناك امر مهم جدا وهو ان الخدمه كذلك
بهذه الاحداث قد انتهتمامك شكرا جزيلا لك
من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشم
ايضا يبتك معنا او معنا الان من الخرطوم
الكاتب الصحفي محمد شمس الدين
محمد هل من مستجدات ايضا على صعيد وتطورات
على صعيد المعارك خصوصا في محيط القصر
الجمهوريه وفي القياده العامه
نعم خالد يعني الوضع فيه نوع من انواع
الهدوء النسبيه الان
الحدود والحذر كما يوصف بين العمليات
القصف التي تتجدد ان تاخرت فتتاخر ربما
لنصف ساعه او اكثر قليلا لالتقاط الانفاس
غالبا هذا الامر يكون لكن بكل اسف شديد
سودانيين يتوقعون هذه ضربات في ايه لحظه
بكل اسف شديد هذا ايضا يضع الناس في حاله
من حالات
الضغط النفسي الرهيب اذا انهم يعني
يتخيلون كل المشاهد التي باتوا يتابعونها
فيما يتعلق
باختراقات النوافذ
وتطير الشظايا او حتى يعني حصول ما حصل
لاحدى شقق السكنيه في مجمع الرواد بالامس
هذه الشقه التي تدمرت بالكامل وهي غالبا
ما تكون جراء قديفه سقطت بالخطا على
المكان او ان لحظه انه يعني هذا المكان
تعرض لمخذوف لحظه الاطلاق من من رشاشات
المضاده للطيران في هذه المنطقه هذا امر
يعني مؤسف طبعا ومتوقع الان في مختلف
مناطق الخرطوم كنا نتوقع ان تكون هذه
الاشتباكات متركزه في منطقه المطار
والقياده العامه ولكن للاسف قبل قليل
تحدثت الى بعض الاصدقاء في منطقه المعموره
قالوا بان الاشتباكات مستمره هناك ايضا
هذه المنطقه تقع الى الجنوب الشرقي من
مطار الخرطوم وهي ما بين شارع الستين
وشارع عبيد ختم هذا حي كبير جدا فيه تركز
السكاني كبير جدا ايضا وهو قريب من منطقه
المدينه الرياضيه التي كانت مسرحا
للاشتباكات في بدايه الامر ايضا وقريب من
معسكر سوبا الخاص بالدعم السريع ايضا
الامر فيما يتعلق به هناك اشتباكات في في
بعض القرى خارج الخرطوم وهذا ما افاد به
بعض المواطنين وهذا كان امر مستغرب منطقه
وادراوه بالام س شهده يعني هذه هذا النوع
من انواع الاشتباكات غير المتوقع في تلك
المناطق اذا لا توجد هناك يعني مواقع
حيويه في هذه المنطقه هي تابعه لولايه
الجزيره هذه المنطقه لا تبعد كثيرا عن
الخرطوم
الامر فيما يتعلق ببقيه الولايات في هدوء
النسبي والسيطره فيه
في اغلبها لقوات الجيش
وكما اسلفنا فان هذه التعزيزات ربما يعني
تكون سببا قدوم هذه التعزيزات الخرطوم
تكون سببا في قدره الجيش على السيطره على
بعض المواقع تتبع للدعم السريع في المواقع
المختلفه في خارج الخرطوم مدى بخصوص بعد
الانسانيه ايضا محمد شمس الدين خصوصا
الاوضاع الاهالي في هذه المناطق التي
تتركز فيها تحتدم هذه الاشتباكه
من الناحيه المعيشيه هناك اوضاع صعبه بكل
امانه ما يتوفر في السوبر ماركتات بات
يتعرض ايضا للسرقه والنهب وهذا امر شوهد
مرارا وتكرارا من قبل هذه القوات
الامر ايضا يعني يجوز او يجدر الحديث عن
اسعار هذه السلع ايضا التي ارتفعت بطريقه
غريبه جدا يعني
لا اعرف لماذا هذا النوع من انواع
الاستغلال في الاسعار هناك بعض التجار لم
يقوموا بتغيير الاسعار وهذا امر يحمد لهم
لكن هناك امر غريب جدا يحصل عند بعض
التجار حينما يعني يعرضون اسعارهم الجديده
الغريبه وذلك بمبرر شح المعروض وزياده
الطلب وهذا امر غريب جدا في هذه الظروف
هذا امر لم يعهده السودانيون من قبل وفي
هذه الحاله ما زالت النداءات تتوجه نحو
شركات المواد الغذائيه لان تنزل فعلا
شاحنات كبيره تقوم بتوزيع المواد الغذائيه
بشكل رمزي او بنصف السعر حتى او يعني
لتخفف عن الناس لان هناك ازمه حقيقيه الان
ليس فقط في توفر الكاش اليوم تطبيق بنكك
الذي يعتمد عليه كل السودانيون متعطل في
في معاملاتهم اليوميه وعمليات الشراء
اليوميه البسيطه حتى متعطل تماما منذ
مسائل الامس وهذا احدث ربكه كبيره في حياه
الناس
خدمه الحصول على الرصيد للهاتف ايضا متعطل
لانه الجميع مرتبط بهذا التطبيق هناك
تطبيقات اخرى تعمل ولكن هذا التطبيق هو
الاكثر انتشارا في السودان ويعاني منه
السودانيون مرارا وتكرارا وهذا نداء يوجه
الان الى اداره البنك للمسارعه في اصلاح
خلل الحاصل في سيرفرات هذا التطبيق
حياه الناس معتمده عليه كليا في
المستشفيات نحن نشاهد عمليات الدفع تتم
قبل الدخول الى عمليات مستعجله مثلا عبر
هذا التطبيق ايضا الامر ليس رفاهيه هذا
التطبيق يعني من الاهميه بمكان والمع
كبيره نتيجه لهذا الامر اليوم خدمه
الكهرباء ايضا يعتمد عليها الناس ايضا من
هذا التطبيق بكل اسف يعني نقول ان التعطل
يضر بمصالح الناس هذا فيما يتعلق بالامور
هي فيما يتعلق بالمستشفيات هناك نداءات
متتاليه من نقابه الاطباء فيما يتعلق
بانقطاع الامدادات الطبيه
وضروره ان تبتعد هذه العمليات من
المستشفيات اذ ان هناك مشاهد مؤسفه شوهدت
ونقلت على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لمرضى
الكلى وهم يحاولون الفرار وتنقل ما بين
مكان واخر كذلك هناك مرضى لم يتمكن من
الوصول اصلا الى هذه المستشفيات المعنيه
شكرا جزيلا لكم محمد شمس الدين الكاتب
الصحفي من الخرطوم
لاول مره وسيله اعلاميه ستدخل الى هذا
الجزء من مطار مروي العسكري
ستتابعون الان هذه الصور لحجم الضرر الذي
لحق بالمطار
الاليات العسكريه في هذا المكان حجم
الدمار كما تتابعون دمارك كامل حريق كامل
لهذه الاليات
احترقت بكاملها نتيجه للاشتباكات
والعمليات
المسلحه
ونذكر ونشير ايضا بان سلاح المهندسين
التابع للقوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
ينتشر في محيط مروي
وداخل القاعده ليمشط وليتعامل مع الاجسام
الغير منفجره التي ايضا ربما تشكل عبئا
ثقيلا على بقيه القوات الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه وتشكل ايضا خطوره على المواطنين
في المناطق المحيطه بمطار مروي الدولي
والعسكري التحرك في هذه النقطه هو التحرك
بحذر لا يمكن ان نتعمق اكثر من واقع محمد
هنا بعض
الاجسام التي ما زالت مشتعله
تلاحظون الان هذا الدخان
هذه الاليه
هذه الاليه الان ما زالت النار مشتعله في
هذا الجزء من المطار يبدو انها نتيجه لاخر
ضربات عسكريه كانت هنا في هذه المنطقه
هذا هو الوضع للاليات المحترقه اليات
مدنيه وسيارات تتبع لمطار مروي الدولي
والقاعده الجويه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
على صعيد الجهود الاقليميه نحو الخارجات
الفرنسيه للعربيه انها تناسق مع السعوديه
والامم المتحده للتوصل الى هدنه الطوارئ
في السودان قبل ذلك بحث وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
تطورات الاوضاع في السودان وداعا الوزيران
الى وقف اطلاق النار والتصعيد العسكري
وانهاء العنف وحمايه المدنيين وتوفير
الممرات الامنه للعمليات الانسانيه بدات
السياق بحث الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي مع الرئيس الاماراتي الشيخ محمد بن
زايد التطورات في السودان ودعى الرئيسان
الى وقف التصعيد والعوده للحوار بين
الاطراف المتحاربه كما اكد على ضروره
العوده للمسار السياسي
وفيما يتعلق بشبهه التدخل الليبي في
الصراع السوداني نفت القوات المسلحه
الليبيه بقياده خليفه حفتر تقديم اي دعم
لاي طرف ضد الاخر من طرفي الصراع الدائره
في السودان
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تدعو وتناشد بذروت الوقوع الوقف
والفوري الاقتتال بين الاشقاء بدوله
السودان الشقيقه وعلى اهميه توفير الظروف
المناسبه للتحديه
وتغليب المصلحه الوطنيه العليا وانتهاز
هذه الايام المباركه بحلول عيد الفطر
المبارك لوقف كافه الاعمال العسكريه وذلك
للمساهمه في استعاده استقرار الاوضاع
بالبلاد عبر التواصل والتنسيق بين جميع
الاطراف بغيت ايجاد الارضيه المشتركه
للتوافق والخروج من الازمه الحاليه
وتداعياتها محليا واقليميا ودوليا وفي هذا
صدد فان القياده العامه تنفي نفيا قاطعا
ما تتناوله بعض وسائل الاعلام الرخيصه
والمازوره بقيام القوات المسلحه العربيه
الليبيه تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد الطرف الاخر
بل نحن كنا وما زلنا وسنظل مع استقرار
دوله السودان وامنها وسلامتها وسلامه
شعبها العربي الافريقي الاصيل وتقوم حاليا
باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع الاطراف
المعنيه وبيننا مستعدين للقيام بدور
الوساطه بين الاشقاف السودان لوقف القتال
فورا وفتح المجال للحوار بالطرق السلميه
الدكتور محمد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر والدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور محمد
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابع لماذا
ما زال الجانب العربي يعني فيما يبدو
الاقل فعاليه في ايجابي حل لهذه الازمه هل
تتفق اولا مع هذا الراي
يعني ربما لا تثق بصوره كامله لانه كافه
الدول العربيه بذلت مجهودات كبيره في
التواصل مع طرفها الصراع وطلبت نوع من
التهدئه واعتقد انها ما زالت تدرس كيفيه
الوساطه بين الطرفين لكن الموقع الموقف
المعقد عسكريا هو الذي يحول دون نجاح
الوسطات او بلورت وساطه فاعله بين الطرفين
يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه مصر
لجامعه الدول العربيه وجهت نداءات
بالاضافه الى دول اخرى لكن لم تبلور يعني
صيغه معينه او مبادره معينه محدده النقاط
تستطيع ان تحقق انجاز لماذا لان الموقف
العسكري على والواقع العسكري على الارض
معقد للغايه
وكل طرف
يفتقد الثقه في الطرف الاخر افتخاد الثقه
هو اللي ادى الى
الهدنه الانسانيه لم تستمر وتم اختراقها
لان كل طرف يريد ان يحقق مكاسب في ذلك
ويريد ان يذهب الى مائده التفاوض ولديه
الاوراق التي تفرض وجهه نظره على الطرف
الاخر هذا ما يمكن العمل حتى الان كما لا
توجد وسائل للضغط على الطرفين لقبول
الوساطه اذا نحن ننتظر الى ان يعني يحسم
التوازن العسكري على الارض بصوره نوبه
اخرى تدفع الطرفين لقبول الوساطه وعندها
تتبلور وساطه او اخرى الاحاد الافريقي
والايجاد طرح وساطه ما زالت متعسره مصر
نسقت مع رئيس جنوب السودان في وساطه ولكنه
ذهب بعدها الى المحور الافريقي في الوساطه
الخاصه بالايجاد ولم تتبلور صيغه حتى الان
والجميع يتحدث انه اجر اتصالات بالطرفين
وطلب ضبط النفس ووقف اطلاق النار دون
تحقيق اي انجاز على هذا المستوى وعلى
مستوى العمل الرسمي يعني الجامعه العربيه
عقدت اجتماع في السادس عشر من ابريل كانت
بدعوه من السعوديه
مصر لمناقشه الوضع في السودان لكن
نفس العمل الذي يتخذ دائما نفس الاجراءات
الروتينيه التي اعتادت عليها مع كل ازمه
يعني تندلع في اي بلد عربي لا تتجاوز
البيانات الدعوه الى الوقف الفوري لكافه
الاشتباكات المسلحه هل هي بسبب الوضع
العسكري الان والاشتباكات ليست قادره على
فعل اكثر من ذلك ام ما زالت في موقف
المتفرج يعني تنتظر ان ياتي الحل من القوى
الدوليه الكبرى دكتور محمد يعني هو في
نقطتين النقطه الاولى كما سبقا اوضح ان
الوضع العسكري لا يسمح بالتدخل الوساطه في
الوقت الحالي لانه يجري تدمير لقوات
الطرفين الجيش اعتبر الطرف الاخر
متقوه متمرده يجب استئصالها ويتم والطرف
الاخر بدا يتحدث عن انه يسعى الى
الديمقراطيه وان الجيش لا يسعى وهناك
اعلاميه وتفضيل اعلامي كبير فالواقع ما
زال موجود كما هو الاطراف ذات الصله
بالطرفين لم تمارس الضغوط المطلوبه الموقف
الامريكي يتحدث عن فرض عقوبات ولكنه لم
يتحرك بصوره جديه لاحداث للضغط على
الطرفين ربما لا يملك اوراق الضغط حتى
الان او ربما ينتظر ان تتعقد الازمه ويمكن
ان نذهب في ذلك للصيغه التي حدثت في ليبيا
او حدثت في العراق وضعها تحت الفصل السابع
وتصبح باسها تدفع بعد ذلك الموقف السوداني
الى التردد اما فيما يتعلق بجامعه الدول
العربيه
فلعلكها ترى ان مؤسسات العمل العربي
المشتركه ضعيفه للغايه وتحتاج الى دوله
تستطيع صياغه تحالف عربي يتحرك وتقود هذه
الحركه بحيث تكون يعني بديلا للعمل
الجماعي المتعثر داخل المؤس الخاصه بالعمل
العربي المشترك فالجامعه ليس لها حضور لا
في الازمه السودانيه ولم تكن لها حضور في
الازمه الليبيه عكس الاتحاد الافريقي ولا
في الازمه السوريه فهي يعني انعكاس لطبيعه
الخلافات العربيه
وعدم توحد الرؤى فيما يتعلق بذلك وهم
يستدعي ان تكون هناك دوله تتصدر المشهد
وتكود تحالف معين بمن حضر لمواجهه تلك
الازمات دكتور ساعود اليك نتابع في متابعه
هذه التطورات
المتعلقه بالحرب في السودان
الفرقه الثانيه
هذه عربات قوات الدعم السريع بولايه
القضارف الفرقه الثانيه مشاه الذين
استولوني عليها
ان شاء الله وهو النصر
مزيد من العربات
[موسيقى]
الفرقه الثانيه
القوات المسلحه
الفرقه الثانيه مشاه
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
اولاد العويل جروا جروا
الله اكبر
الدكتور محمد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر والدراسات الاستراتيجيه فكره ان
تنتظر هذه الدول الان ما ستنتجه الحرب
يعني من ميل لكافه طرف على الاخر اليس في
ذلك مراهنه على السيناريو الاخطر دكتور
محمد الزيات من قبل الدول العربيه يعني
تعلم بان
حسم الحرب ربما لصالح طرف على الاخر في
حرب شوارع الان تشهدها العاصمه الخرطوم في
وضع يبدو ان كل طرف هو مستعد اصلا للوصول
الى هذه الحاله من الانفجار بالتالي
استمرارها الى فتره اطول ستجعل السودان
كلها
وتدخل في حرب اهليه لا يمكن بعد ذلك ابدا
يعني
التدخل فيها يعني ستكون ساحه الاستقطاب
حاد بين كل الدول اليس كذلك فذكرته يا
استاذ خالد هو السيناريو الاسود الذي تؤكد
معطيات العمليات العسكريه الجاريه الان ان
السودان بالاتجاه اليها يعني كل طرف يتجه
الى حسد لصالحه لا شوائد على الوصول
الطرفين الى نقطه توازن تسمح بقبول
التفاوض ولكن ما زالت الاجنده الواضحه هي
استئصال الطرف الاخر كاملا وكل طرف يدعي
ان لديه القدره على تحقيق ذلك هذا
السيناريو سيء
وخطورته ليست فقط على السودان ولكن على
دول الجوار ومن اولها مصر لانك تجاور
لمنطقه مملوءه كما سبق ان قلت بتنظيمات
الارهاب في منطقه الساحل والصحراء
واستمرار العمليات العسكريه تنذر بدخول
عناصر من الخارج يعني بالامس قالت شاهد ان
فرقه كامله من الجيش لجات الى اراضيها اذا
مناطق الحدود مفتوحه للدخول والخروج
والسلاح سيصبح متاحا في ضرب المخازن وضرب
المعسكرات فيتاح لم تنظيمات اخرى مخت اذا
نحن باتجاه الى سيناريو اسوا لحرب اهليه
واسعه اذا لم يتم الضغط الان على الطرفين
لتحقيق نقطه مبدئيه وقف اطلاق النار اولا
لفتره معينه ثم طرح المبادرات التي تستوعب
مواقف الطرفين هل تبدو الدول العربيه
متفقه الان اما ام ان بالفعل السوداني
يشهد حاله استقطاب من دول العربيه نفسها
يعني في التعامل مع الموقف
لصالح طرف دون اخر وهو سبب كما يقول البعض
في عدم الضغط من اي طرف على الطرف الذي
يعني يقترب منه ويتجه اليه لايقاف هذه
الحرب هل هذه الفكره ايضا منطقيه وارده
هي وارده بالفعل لكن لو تم لقاء ما واتصور
لو التقت المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومصر
ودوله الامارات
والجزائر مثلا وجلسوا الامور ستكون اكثر
انكشافا في مواقف كل طرف وتطرح المبدا
الاساسي من يملك التاثير على طرف عليه ان
يطلب منه وقف اطلاق النار مجرد وقف اطلاق
النار فتره بدل فتره انسانيه لفتح
المسارات الامنه للمواطنين يعني دوافع
انسانيه لكن تكون ممتده في هذه اللحظه
يمكن تلمس وسائل التعامل مع الطرفين لكن
لن نصل لنتيجه طالما استمرت الموقف في
توجيهات لكل منهما وطالما انتظرنا الحسم
العسكري الذي سوف يكون نتائجه كارثيه اولا
على الشعب السوداني شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
محمد الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
تابع لقوات الدعم السريع بعد ان قاموا
هاربين منها
باستلام عدد خمس عربه لاندك وعدد واحد
تنكر ماء وعدد جاك همر وكميه من الاسلحه
بفضله في هذه الساعه
وتم الاستدلال على عدد خمسه عرب كنوزر
[تصفيق]
ما هنا يا جماعه
هذه ايضا صوره انتظر قصف عده مستشفيات في
مدينه الابيض شمال
في الموقف الامريكي دانا مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي استمرار العنف في السودان
اليوم السادس داعيا طرفي الصراف لوقف
الاعمال العدائيه فورا
ومؤكدا على تاييده لتطلعات الشعب السوداني
في الانتقال الديمقراطي السلمي من جهه
اخرى فادت صحيفه
تستعد لفرض عقوبات على طرفي النزاع في
السودان تشير المصادر الى ان العقوبات
التي لم تنجز بعد
ستطالوا مسؤولين في القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريعه على حد
بسبب الاقتدات هي اعرب مسؤولون امريكيون
عن مخاوفهم من ان العقوبات لن تكون كافيه
وتاتي متاخره
المواجهه العسكريه بين قائد القوات
المسلحه ونائبه صورتها صحيفه
اعلاميا وجها لوجه خصمان قويان مصممان على
القتال حتى النهايه كل منهما لن يتراجع
حتى تحقيق اهدافه ويرمي كره التهدئه في
ملعب الاخر وفق تصريحات الطرفين الصحيفه
مواجهه البرهان واحمد العسكريه بارض
المعركه يقابلها تنافس اعلامي لا يقل حده
وفي وقت اكد احمد عدم التراجع عن اهدافه
على اعتبار ان ارض المعركه ستحدد كل شيء
لفت البرهان الى خروج جزء كبير من قوه
احمدتي عن السيطره قائد قوه الدعم السريع
اعتبر ان البرهان ليس مستعدا للانتقال
للحكم المدني لكن الاخيره اكد استئناف
الانتقال للمسار الديمقراطي بمجرد هزيمه
احمد
اهداف احمدتي تشمل اعتقال البرهان
ومحاكمته اهداف تبين محاوله الدعم السريع
الاستيلاء على السلطه وفق البرهان حمدتي
شدد على عدم معارضه دمج قواته بالجيش من
حيث المبدا الجيش اكد الالتزام باستكمال
العمليه السياسيه وفق الاتفاق الايطالي
ترشق كلامي يستكمله احمدتي بتاكيد انفتاحه
على وقف اعمال العطف لكنه يؤكد ايضا ان
البرهان لن يتوقف فيما يتهم قائد الجيش
قوه
باعمال نهب
الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الامريكيه دكتور وليد اهلا وسهلا بك معي
في نشره الرابع الدكتور بالنظر الى ما جاء
في صحيفه الفورم بوليسي الامريكان جاد في
معالجه الازمه في السودان وهل فكره
العقوبات بان تفرض على الطرفين اذا تم ذلك
فعليا يعني هل هي الحلانسه
اولا بالنسبه لموضوع العقوبات هي اول
اشاره الى نوع من محاوله التدخل الامريكي
في الموضوع يعني اشاره اوتوماتيكيه ولكن
كان اعترافا من قبل الاداره انه ليس هنالك
اعتقاد انه وضع عقوبات على الطرفين بشكل
متناسب سوف يكون بابا للحل يعني هذه
قالوها وكانوا صريحين فيها المشكله انه
بواشنطن كان هنالك كانت هنالك مراقبه لما
يجري في السودان منذ اشهر ولكن لم يكن
هنالك لم تكن هنالك مبادرات لانه
المعلومات التي وصلت الى واشنطن عبر
الاجهزه الاستخبارات والدبلوماسيه طبعا
واشنطن لها اعين داخل السودان كما في باب
الدول كانت انه عمليا الوضع ممكن تهدئته
كما هو عليه بالضغوطات الى ما هنالك لانه
هنالك ساحات كثيره وملفات كثيره لها
اولويه في واشنطن وعندما انفجر الوضع
بامكاني ان اقول انه كان مفاجئا لكثيرين
في وشر ان يصل هذا الانفجار الى هذا الحد
والتحليل حسب فهمي ان واشنطن تعت
انه الجغرافيه
الاشتباك في السودان يعني يختلف عن مجرى
في ليبيا او في اليمن ليس هنالك مناطق
سيطره خاصه
بمجموعه حتى الان هذا قد يحصل في المستقبل
من هنا الصعوبه الصعوبه التدخل يبقى كما
قال ضيوفكم في الماضي مبادرات عربيه قد
تدعمها واشنطن انه لا اعتقد ستكون هنالك
مبادره امريكيه ولكن سوف تكون هنالك
مبادره اقليميه او عربيه تدعمها
والاتحاد الاوروبي
العقوبات يعني مساله العقوبات اذا ما عدنا
اليها ليست متاخره هل يمكن فعليا لوشنطن
ان تفرض عقوبات على طرفين على الدعم
السريع الدعم السريع الذي يقال بان له
علاقات بروسيا دكتور ومجموعه الفاغنر
الدعم السريع الذي اتهماه واشنطن مباشره
على لسان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن بانهم هم من كانوا وراء استهداف
الموكب الامريكي الموكب الدبلوماسي
الامريكي هل ذلك وارد بالنسبه لواشنطن
كل هذا الكلام كل هذه الوقائع التي تفضلتم
بها الصحيحه ودقيقه وهذا ما سمعناه هنا في
واشنطن ولكن هنالك مشكله في اتخاذ القرار
في وشم خاصه في هذه الظروف بالفعل
العقوبات كان يجب وضعها قبل سته اشهر يعني
عندما بدانا نرى ان هنالك في احتمال
لتفجير حرب اهليه وقتها تنفع للعقوبات
يعني هي الضغط وتذيب لا تذهب الى العراق
والا العراق بمعنى الكاف والا سوف نضع هذه
العقوبات ان نضع العقوبات بعد ان بدات
المواجهات وهي تمتد وكانها تذهب الى
حرباليه هي لم تصل بعد الى هذا المستوى
هذا امر يعني حتى واشنطن عالمه به المشكله
الان من له قدره دبلوماسيه اقتصاديه ان
يضغط على الطرفين ليس فقط بالعقوبات ولكن
بالضغط يعني قطع
المدخول بالنسبه لهما او اهم من ذلك
واعتقد لا احد يريد ان يتحمل هذا الموضوع
من بامكانه ان يتدخل برضا الطرفين بقوه
معينه مشتركه من المنطقه او دوليا لحسم
الموضوع ضد الحرب لما يجري الان اذا سالت
اي عاصمه اقليميه او في الولايات بعد
الامريكيه هل بامكانكم ان تتصوروا سيناريو
لقوه ثالثه تدخل وتفصل بالطبع الجواب الان
هو لا
دكتور هل يمكن ان تتحول السوداني لساحه
استقطاب الدولية البعض يتحدث على انه
بالفعل الان هناك استقطاب اقليمي يعني
على مستوى المنطقه قد يكون ذلك سببا او
عائقا في عدم اتخاذ اي قرار عربي فاعليه
حتى الان فعليا انسحب الامر كذلك بان
يتحول الى هذه الساحه وهو السبب الرئيسي
في عدم ايجاد حتى اي حل حتى الان يعني
يتحدث عن الصراع الامريكي الروسي الدكتور
دعني لو سمحت اتكلم بضعه ثواني عن الوضع
الاقليمي وانتقل منه الى الوضع الدولي
لانه هو يؤثر على ذلك
لاحظنا في هذا الصراع قصير العمر ان شاء
الله ينتهي ان هنالك كانن في العواصم
العربيه من تسميه من هي الاطراف الاخرى
التي تتدخل في السودان هذا واضح في
الاعلام وفي البيانات الحكوميه كل
البيانات تاتي وتقول نحن نطلب من الطرفين
ان لا يكون لا حصانين لاطراف اقليميه ولكن
لا احد يسمي من هي هذه الاطراف الصينيه
لانه ثلاث كل مشكله اقليميه في هذا الظروف
صعبه
يحدث هذا الشيء لننتقل الى وضع الدول
الوضع الدولي تقريبا واضح تقريبا واضح انه
قوات الدعم السريع وقيادتها هم على علاقه
بروسيا والمجموعات الروسيه على الارض
وحلفاء روسيا على الارض في المنطقه هذا
يبقي انه القوات الجيش او
الشرعيه السودانيه هي تحصل على دعم دولي
وبما فيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن
بنفس الوقت هنالك مدرسه في واشنطن وهذا
يعقد الامور تقول ان القوتان العسكريتان
غير مفروض ان يكونوا هون في الحكم الان
يجب تعجيل موضوع الحكم المدني يعني لذلك
نرى من وزاره الخارجيه تركز على من هي
الاطراف التي هي قادره ان تاتي وتنقض ولكن
هذه الاطراف المدنيه عندما تحصل اشتباكات
عسكريه بهذا الحجم يصعب ان يكون لها دور
من هنا التعقيد الموجود في واشنطن
تمام دكتور هل هذا يمكن ان يعني ان واشنطن
ستضغط خلال فترات القادمه وهنا دعني استند
الى بعض ما تسرب من انباء خلال الايام
القليله ايام لم يتم تاكيدا لكن انتشرت
اعلاناتها او نشرتها بعد وسائل على
الامريكيه بان واشنطن تضغط على القاهره من
اجل ان تدعم مصر سياسيا وعسكريا الجيش
السوداني ضد حمدي هل هذا الامر قد يعني
ينساق الى ضغطه امريكي على كل الدول
العربيه في اتخاذ هذا هذا النهج الان او
الانحياز
هنالك بعض الافكار في هذا الاتجاه ولكن
هنالك قلق امريكي حتى من هذا الاتجاه
ساشرح واوقف بسرعه هنالك بالطبع اتجاهي
واشنطن للمحادثه والكلام مع القاهره
موجوده على الحدود دوله عربيه كبرى مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الان واشنطن سوف
تحتاج الى الى الرياض وحكمتها وقدرتها لكي
يقوموا بنوع من الاستقرار وحصر نفوذ
قوات المعارضه في السودان ولكن ما تخشاه
واشنطن اذا قامت هي مع مبادره عربيه
بالضغط باتجاه معين سوف ذلك يفتح الباب
لروسيا ان تتدخل اكثر هي هي تريد حل هذا
الموضوع دبلوماسيا لانه اذا كان الحل غير
دبلوماسي واذا كان الحل تصادمي هذا سوف
يعطي روسيا وحلفاء روسيا في المنطقه قادره
على التدخل اكثر مما سيجعل من السودان
يعني للاسف لا اريد ان اذكر هذا الموضوع
واما سوريا اما الصومال اخر هذا الامر لا
تريده هل هو سيناريو الاقرب الان دكتور
فريد
ان تتحول السوداني الى سوريا وليبيا
اشت الان اذا لم تتوقف بعد اسبوع واذا لم
تكن هنالك قدره دوليه او اقليميه للتدخل
ولو بدات بالتدخل بطريقه ما يتجه السودان
للاسف الى مواجهه شامل وانا خشيتي انه هذه
المواجهه لن تكون فقط في الخرطوم ولكن في
مناطق اخرى في السودان لها مشاكلها وهذا
من هذه بدات مؤشرات بدات بعض يعني هذه
الشرارات هذه الحرب في اكثر من ولايه في
في دارفور في في الولايات ايضا اخرى
متفرقه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور وليد فارس
الخبير في السياسه الامريكيه ضيفني اهلا
بكم
المعارك مستمره والحسم لا يزال مبكرا وفقا
للعديد من المراقبين مع التحول المواجهات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريعه
الى مواجهات مدن مفتوح راويه القاسم
تعطينا لمحه عن سير المعارك في الايام
الماضيه
الى حرب مدن مفتوحه وفيما الحسم
رهن بالايام المقبله يواصل الطرفان
عملياتهما الجيش اعلن عن استعاده مطار
مروي وسلاح المهندسين ومنشات حول مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم
حيث ما تزال قوات الدعم موجوده هناك قوات
حمايه فشلت بتحييد القواعد الجويه
والمطارات الاساسيه في البلاد خلافا
لخطتها الاساسيه فبعد اقتحامها لمطار مروي
شمال السودان واعلانها السيطره عليه عاد
الاخير لقبضه الجيش السوداني واقتصرت
مكاسبها جويا على قاعده جبل اولياء جنوب
العاصمه اضافه الى مطارين في دارفور هما
مطار الفاشر شمالا ومطار صبيره الدولي
غربا فشل قوات الدعم السريع بالسيطره على
كافه القواعد الجويه مكن الجيش من استخدام
لاستهداف تمركزات وسيارات الدعم السريع
بالعاصمه تحديدا وهي اليات غير مدرعه وهي
سهله التدبير كما معهد استخدام سلاح الجو
الطريق امام الجيش للسيطره على مقرات
رئيسيه لقوات الدعم السريع في محيط
العاصمه كمعسكرات سوبا جنوب خرطوم في
الطيبه والطيبه في شمالها والصالحه ايضا
وكرري في ام درمان كما نشاهد وضمنت كذلك
عدم تمكن الدعم السريع من الحفاظ على
مقراتها التي تحتوي على احتياطيات لوجستيا
في ولايتي النيل الازرق والنيل الابيض
وبورسودان والقضارف وكسله اما نجاحات قوات
الدعم السريع فتتمثل بقطع التواصل بين
شمال العاصمه وايضا جنوبها من خلال
سيطرتها على الجسور وتعطيل حركه المرور
من القاهره احمد علي بالباحث في وحده
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
سيدي احمد اهلا وسهلا بك معي في حرب
الشوارع الان التي نشاهدها في الخرطوم من
يمتلك القدره الاكبر على القتال قوات
الدعم السريع حميدتي الجيش والبرهان
يعني المعادله حتى الان خاصه بالاشتراك ما
بين الطرفين تشير الى انه ربما يكون هناك
نوع من
التكافؤ الى حد ما لا يستطيع اي طرف ان هو
يحسم المعركه في ظل انه هي حرب شوارع في
وسط اكبر كتله سكانيه موجوده في العاصمه
بالنظر للاهداف الثلاثه الذين يناور كل
طرف اما للدفاع عنها او المحاوله السيطره
عليها وبالتالي فيما يتعلق
[موسيقى]
الهجوم والهجوم المضاد في منطقه المركز
اللي هي العاصمه انا بعتقد انه الرهان هنا
على او التوصيل الدقيق هي فكره تبادل
اللكمات ما بين الطرفين هذا الامر يختلف
الى احد ما في
الانتشار في الاطراف او المواقع الاخرى
واللي هي تم فيها اضعاف
تشكيلات وقدرات
القوات الدعم السريع من اتجاه الشرق على
اعتبار المياه عددا مع تركيز قوات الدعم
السريع على محاوله السيطره اكثر على
المناطق اللي موجوده لها في الغرب خاصه في
الفاشر وفي منطقه الجنينه وده لمحاوله
تامين خط العوده الى هذه المناطق اللي
كانت بتمثل لها من قبل
المعقل الرئيسي لكن ايضا هي كان عندها قدر
من
التخطيط في بدايه الامر لانه المعسكرات
السته اللي ذكرت في التقرير الان هي لما
بنشوفها على الخريطه بنلاقي ان هي متوزعه
تقريبا في كل الاتجاهات الاستراتيجيه اللي
موجوده في محيط العاصمه صنعاء في محيط
العاصمه الخرطوم وبالتالي كان الهدف هو مش
السيطره عليها بشكل كبير لانه قوات الدعم
ليست مؤهله باي شكل او باخر هذا الامر لكن
ربما هي كانت محاوله استفزاز واستدراج
محاوله ايضا
للاستنزاف والانهاك يعني لا اعتقد انه
قوات الدعم
واسعه من مناطق حيويه او من قواعد عسكريه
زي ما حصل في مروي بالاساس لكن هي لما
نيجي نشوف مثلا هي في مروي عملت ايه هي
دخلت
القاعده الجويه لنقطه المطار برج المراقبه
لتعطيل عمليات برج المراقبه فبالتالي
هيكون عندها هدف معين وليس فكره السيطره
كامله لانها لا تستطيع ان تفعل ذلك
وبالتالي احنا سواء في منطقه المركز او في
منطقه الاطراف احنا عندنا في تطور في
الاشتباك
وعلى انه مستوى التكتيكات ما عندناش تطور
كبير او فارغ وبالتالي كاميرات ممتازه
الان الان جيش السوداني في هذا الخبر
العاجل يقول لا وجود لقوات مسلحه خارج
منظومه الجيش بعد اليوم هذا يعني ان الحرب
ستكون الى النهايه
لقضاء طرف على الاخر هذا الى اي مدى سيجعل
الحرب تاخذ مدن طويلا دكتور وما خطوره هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
من صواريخ والطائرات وغيرها في مقابل قوات
الدعم السريع يعني هل هي قادره على
الاستمرار دعني مثلا سيطره هذه القوات على
مناجم الذهب في في الولايات الشماليه
انشطتها التجاريه ايضا الكبيره والواسعه
عبر الحدود هل سيجعلها قادره على
الاستمرار يعني على تحقيق الاكتفاء ذاتي
مالي وبالتالي الدعم والمسانده وغيرها من
الامور لفتره حرب اطول
ايضا يا استاذ خالد انا اتصور انه
الخلفيات السياسيه اكثر تاثيرا فيما يتعلق
بهذا الجانب من الخلفيات العسكريه بمعنى
ان الجيش السوداني بعد ازمه دارفور في
ما قبل تقريبا كانت من الشكل الجنجويد
وكانت يعني دائما تطورها الدعم انا اعتقد
انه المساله هنا
لم يكن بمقدوره ان هو يلعب دور في هذه
المنطقه مساله تشكل الامراض امراء الذهب
وامراء الحرب وكل هذه العلاقات اللي بتنشا
في اطار مثل هذه المصالح المشتركه ما بين
امراء الحرب وامراء الجريمه المنظمه
وعصابات تهريب السلاح واصابات الحدود
الشرعيه والى اخره يعني كل هذه البيئات
موجوده في مناطق الحدود او مناطق الاطراف
غير المنضبطه وده واضح تماما في اطار
طبيعه الحدود ما بين شمال غرب السودان
وجنوب ليبيا والمساحه مع انشاء وده شقه
ثروات كبيره وتحولت ايضا هذه يعني هذا
الطابع تحول الى نوع من المؤسسه يعني
اصبحت الامور واضحه تماما
واصبح ايضا
حاولت الى شركات دوليه ليس فقط الى شركات
محليه ولكن شركات نقل شركات دوليه مع بعض
الاطراف شكرا جزيلا لك احمد علي باحثه
الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه بمركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
اطباء السودان تكشف ايضا عن ارقام صادمه
للمستشفيات التي اصبحت خارج الخدمه في ظل
استمرار للاشتباكات في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريعه
حرب داميه دفعت النظام الصحي في السودان
الى حافه الانهيار لتصبح الازمه ازمتين
تزيد من ماساه الشعب السوداني الذي اثخن
بالجراح في بلد لم يعرف الاستقرار التام
منذ عقود وهو الان ضحيه السيناريو الاسود
ارقام صادمه لعدد المستشفيات التي اصبحت
خارج الخدمه في ذروه احتياج المواطنين لها
سبعون في المئه من المرافق الصحيه اوقفت
عن العمل او اجبرت على الاغلاق بحسب نقابه
اطباء السودان فمن اصل 74 مستشفى في
العاصمه والولايات التي تقع بالقرب من
مناطق الاشتباك يوجد 52 مستشفى منها اصبحت
خارج الخدمه تماما بعد الاشتباكات الاخيره
تسعه مستشفيات منها تعرضت القصف الشديد
و19 مستشفى اخر تعرضت للاخلاء القصري ما
يعني وجود
مستشفى فقط في المنطقه تعمل بشكل كامل او
جزئي وهي الاخرى مهدده بالاغلاق في اي
لحظه بسبب انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وانعدام الادويه وغياب الكوادر الصحيه
فهذه المرافق الطبيه تعمل بالحد الادنى من
الامكانيات والحد الاقصى من انعدام الامن
حولها
نظام الرعايه الصحيه في السودان يمكن ان
ينهر تماما تحتاج المستشفيات الى موظفين
اضافي وتحتاج الى امدادات اضافيه وتحتاج
الى امدادات دم اضافي هناك تقريبا هجوم
عسكري على عدد من المؤسسات الصحيه هناك
يعني هجوم على سيارات اسعاف وبها مرضى
وبها عاملين صحيين وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
التحذيرات الدوليه من كارثه انسانيه
وانهيار القطاع الصحي في البلاد الا ان
القتال لا زال يتواصل في عاصمه السودانيه
ومدن اخرى
لنعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
معنا الان في استديوهاتنا من الرياض لنمره
اخرى كيف تتدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه تاثير
ايضا على القطاع الصحي في ضوء هذه
الشهادات التي تاتي سواء من الداخل له
دوليه ايضا
نعم خالد الشيء الجيد هو ما اشرت اليه
انها تاتي الان من الداخل والخارج في وقت
سابق كان فقط من هم موجودون في المستشفى
يتحدثون عن سوء الاوضاع وعن ازدحام
المستشفى مما بضباط وجنود دخلوا الى
المستشفى لتلقي العلاج للجروح التي لحقت
بهم او انها ايضا نسبه لتكدس مرضى داخل
بعض المستشفيات الان هذا هذه الشهادات
التي تاتي من الخارج تؤكد بصوره واضحه بان
هناك
سوء في الاوضاع الانسانيه بعلم المنظمات
الدوليه والجهات المسؤوله من العمل الصحي
طبعا وزاره الصحه تحدثت نقابه الاطباء
المرضى ايضا تحدثوا تحدث كثير من
العاملين في المجال الطوعي كثير من
الصيادله الذين يقومون بتقديم الدواء الان
الخطوره ايضا في هذه المستشفيات هي نقص
الاكسجين وعدم قدره العاملين المستشفى على
الاتيان بهذا الاكسجين وهذه الشركات التي
تعمل في المجال الصحي مغلقه حتى هذا اليوم
هناك محاولات الان تتم بين عاملين في
القطاع الصحي مع هذه الشركات حتى تفتح
بابها وتفتح هذه الشركات تعاملاتها من
جديد
لتمكن المستشفيات من تقديم امدادات طبيه
جديده
الناس في ظل هذه الاوضاع ماذا تفعل كيف
تتعامل مع الموقف
يعني الخياراتهم الان تفكر في ماذا الهروب
البقاء من الثمن الذي يمكن ان تدفعه في
كلا السيناريوهين طبعا خيارات الناس خالد
الان تختلف يعني من منطقه لاخرى من اسره
لاخرى
الخيارات اصبحت متعدده ولكنها ايضا كلها
سيئه بالنسبه للناس يعني ان تترك منزلك
وتذهب الى احدى الولايات السودانيه ان
تفكر في الخروج يعني باي طريق ستسلك قبل
ذلك بالضبط انه حتى هذه اللحظه وبجميع
الاتصالات التي اجريناها اليوم لا شيء امن
هناك محاولات اختبار بعض الاسر تسلك طريق
ثم بعد ذلك تخبر البقيه بان هذا الطريق
اما انهم وجدوا فيه الجيش او وجدوا فيه
الدعوه السريع او انهم لم يزوروا فيه احد
بالتالي الان محاوله المواطنين تتبع
الشوارع اصبح امر ضروري والشيء الجيد انهم
يتعاونون مع بعضهم البعض في بعض صفحات
التواصل الاجتماعي وبعض مجموعات واتساب
لتحديد ان كانت هذه الشوارع والمناطق امنه
ام لا هذا كل ما يستطيع الان السودانيين
القيام به ولكن اما انهم بقيوا في منازلهم
او ذهبوا الى منازل اخرى هي اقل
يعني المناطق اقل قصفه او انهم اتجهوا الى
خيار اخر وهو الذهاب الى ولايه سودانيه
وكل هذه الخيارات هي الان صعبه خاصه انها
مع اواخر شهر رمضان العيد اقترب ازمه
المياه وشح المياه ايضا هذا الوضع كيف اثر
على الناس
ومع احتمالات تطول الحرب
في مداها الزمني يعني
اثرت المياه لانها الان المياه الصحيه
الموجوده حتى مياه الصحه الموجوده في
المحاله التجاريه انتفت امس كان كثير من
الناس يتحدثون انهم افطروا على بيبسي وعلى
بعض العصائر لانعدام المياه لان طبعا نحن
نعرف المياه اصبحت الان لا تستخدم فقط
للشرب مياه الصحه هي تستخدم لاحتياجات
المنزل بالتالي نفاذ مياه الصحه من
المحاله التجاريه امر اثر بصوره مباشره في
ظل انقطاع المياه من كثير من الاحياء شكرا
جزيلا لك مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
الاوضاع
الحاليه في مدينه بورسودان امنه
وقديش السوداني يسيطر لجميع قوات الدعم
السريع والامن مستتب في البحر الاحمر
يعني سعر الحركه مستمر والسوق الحمد لله
نطمنكم تمارين شامل فاتح والمواطنين
بتتسوق الحد الساعه واحده ليلا ونتمنى انه
السوداني يعم الخير والسلام قبل ان نكمل
تغطيه المستمر للاوضاع في السودان دعونا
ان نتابع مجموعه من الاخبار الاخرى حيث
قام الامين العام لخلف شمال الاطلسيه باول
زياره منذ بدايه العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه وسعه النطاق على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه جاءت هذه الزياره التي تندرج
ضمن مسائل حلف مواصله دعم اوكرانيا الوقت
الذي تستعد فيه لشن هجوم المضاد اقدم
ستارتنبرغ خلال هذه الزياره احترامه
للجنود الاوكرانيين الذين قتلوا اثناء
القتال في الحرب وتم استعراض المعدات
العسكريه الروسيه التالفه في ساحه
او في ساحه مركزيه في كيف
[موسيقى]
فقال رئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلنسين
الوقت قد حان لدعوه كياب للانضمام الى خلف
شمال الاطلسي واتخاذ القرار المناسب هذا
جاء في اطار اول زياره يقوم بها الامين
العام لخلف الى تندرج ضمن مساعيه لمواصله
دعم اوكرانيا وشدد زيلينسكي لدى لقائه على
ضروره ان تدعم كل الدول المنخرطه في حلف
الناتو انضمام اوكرانيا الى صفوفه
وقد اعلن ديميتري المتحدث باسم الكريم
هما تحت سيطره الولايات المتحده ويجب
تخفيضهم وقالب سكوب انهم اذا تحدثوا
للولايات المتحده دون مراعات هاتين
الترساني فلا معنى لذلك خاصه ان فرنسا
وبريطانيا نظام متكامل لحلف الناتو الخاضع
لسيطره الولايات المتحده
شهدت ثلاثه مطارات في المانيا حاله من
الاضرابات من عناصر قوات الامن في مطار
هامبورج ودوسلدروف او دوسلدو
ذكر بيان صادر من الجمعيه الالمانيه
للموانئ الجويه انا الاضراب سينتج عنه
الغاء حوالي 700 رحله جويه في المطارات
الثلاث خلال يومي الخميس والجمعه مضيفه
بان حوالي 45 الف مسافر طروا الى تغيير
خطط سفرهم
خلال الساعتين القادمتين تبدا اجراءات
ترائي هلال شهر شوال في السعوديه ودول
عربيه واسلاميه عشره مراصد في السعوديه
خصصت لهذا الغرض ودعت المحكمه العليا ممن
يرى الهلال بالعين المجرده او بواسطه
المناظير الى ابلاغ اقرب محكمه اليه
وتسجيل شهادته فيها او الاتصال بارقب مركز
لمساعدته في الوصول الى اقرب محكمه
تغطيه مستمره زميله ميسون عزام تسحبك
انا اودعكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات